Hi.
Es beginnt heute so früh,
es sollte eigentlich Nachtwache mit Kratky heißen.
Ich bin hier auf der Suche nach den 25ern,
und hier irgendwo sollten sie sein.
Ich glaube ich habe euch gefunden.
Hier fighter Kratky für die 25er.
Erkannt. Weitergehen, hinten ist das Lager.
Danke.
Guten Morgen, da schläft noch einer oder?
Schön, dass du da bist.
Hallo, servus.
Wie du siehst, kochen wir schon einen Kaffee für dich, genieß ihn,
denn danach geht es zum Fallschirmspringen.
Fallschirmspringen?
Ja.
Na dann gehts los.
Zum Wohl. Zum Wohl.
Das ist die C-130 des österreichischen Bundesheeres.
Und das hier ist der Fliegerhorst Provoski
in Langenlebarn.
Und Grüßgott.
Hallo Robert.
Herzlich willkommen beim Jägerbataillon 25.
Gehen wir ein Stück.
Was macht ihr genau?
Das Jägerbataillon 25 ist das einzige Bataillon im österreichischen Bundesheer,
das zur gänze aus Berufssoldatinnen und Berufssoldaten besteht.
Wir sind für Einsätze im Ausland sowohl
aber auch im Inland vorgesehen,
dass heißt wir werden nur für Einsätze bereitgehalten.
Noch dazu sind wir ein Luftlandeverband, dass heißt wir können in den Einsatz gebracht werden
entweder mit Flächenflugzeugen zum Beispiel mit der C-130 hier oder mit Hubschraubern,
um dort dann unsere Einsatzaufgaben zu erfüllen.
Aussteigen tun wir entweder mit dem Fallschirm aus der Luft oder wir landen mit den Hubschraubern.
Ausrüstung ist bei einem militärischen Verband immer ein Top-Thema.
Da haben wir gleich 2 Dinge, die relativ neu sind.
Das stg a2 kommando.
Es ist aber noch immer ein Gasdrucklader mit starrer Verriegelung,
wo die Beladung von unten erfolgt, mittels eines Magazines, welches 30 Schuss fasst.
Genauso ist es.
Weiters haben wir noch das Panzerabwehrrohr, womit man
Leuchtmunition, Panzerabwehrmunition und Sprengmunition verschießen kann.
Es gibt wahnsinnig viele hochinteressante
Jobs beim Bundesheer,
und auch bei euerer Einheit, glaube ich, wäre sogar noch Platz.
Wir haben derzeit 450 Personen bei uns und könnten auf 550-560 anwachsen.
Wer von sich glaubt, dass er das Zeug
zur Fallschirmjägerin oder zum Fallschirmjäger hat,
kann sich jederzeit bei uns melden.
Und es gibt unterschiedliche Jobs.
Wir haben im Fernmeldebereich Arbeitsplätze frei,
wir haben im Sanitätsbereich Arbeitsplätze frei,
bei den Infanteriekompanien,
in der Kampfunterstützungskompanie wo wir Panzerabwehrlenkwaffenzüge haben,
schwere Scharfschützen..
Beeindruckendes Teil, wie viele Leute können
da mit?
40.
Und die springen da raus?
Die springen da raus.
Das schau ich mir dann von hier aus an, weil das sieht sicher großartig aus.
Du hast die Möglichkeit auch von innen das zu machen, gehen wir.
Da rein?
Da rein ja.
Mit euch?
Mit uns.
Kein Problem.
Ich wünsche dir Glück ab und gut Land.
Und das jetzt aufsetzen?
Glück ab und Helm auf.
Wo geht's raus?
Hier.
Ah, ja.
Einfach raus?
Einfach raus.
Sprungtraining, was mich betrifft, ist fürs Erste einmal erledigt.
Wir sehen uns wieder in Allensteig. Das wird richtig interessant.
Alle gut gelandet, wir sind mittlerweilen
wieder in Allensteig.
Da gibt es heute einiges zu sehen.
Hallo Robert, das ist der Iveco,
das neue Allschutztransportfahrzeug des österreichischen Bundesheeres.
Eines der modernsten Geräte, Kanone 12,7mm wird von innen gesteuert.
Hat er auch einen Spitznamen?
Wir nennen ihn einfach "Husar".
Husar. Ok.
Dann setzte ich mich in den Pandur und ihr zeigt was ihr könnt damit.
Das ist unser schweres Scharfschützengewehr 12,7mm,
damit bekämpfen wir Materialziele bis zu einer Entferung von 1800m.
Die schwerste Waffe im Bataillon, ab hier
Helmpflicht,
120mm Granatwerfer, Richtschussweite 7550m.
Damit dieses Gerät schießen kann, brauchen wir einen Beobachter,
der sitzt nebenbei auf der anderen Seite.
Mächtig.
670kg.
Die letzte Waffe des heutigen Tages, Panzerabwehrlenkwaffe 2000.
Aus einem Rohr gestartet, mit einem Draht gelenkt, optisch gesteuert ins Ziel,
um gepanzerte Ziele, Kampfpanzer oder ähnliches, zu bekämpfen.
Bis 2200m.
Jetzt habe ich eine spezielle Weste und einen speziellen Helm bekommen,
jetzt gehts zum Häuserkampf.
Rhenozeros, this is Entertainer, Feueranforderung 1503 Alpha, feuern sofort, over.
Das war ein spektakulärer Tag.
Vom Runterhüpfen, übers unten Ankommen, den Häußerkampf, die Übung.
Du warst ein Teil der Infanteriekompanie.
Hier nutzen wir modernste Mittel um für den Einsatz auszubilden.
Das ist die Echtzeitauswertung und die Simulationsanlage die wir haben.
Da hinten sehen wir bereits die bewegten Bilder, das sind wir im Angriff auf diese Ortskampfanlage.
Man sieht bei jeder einzelnen Soldatin/jeden Soldaten wo er sich gerade befindet,
wie er feuert, wie sich die Truppe bewegt
und kann dann in der Analyse ganz genau schauen,
wo man sich verbessern kann.
Das ist unglaublich professionell.
Ein unglaubliches Panoptikum an fantastischen, interessanten und fordernden Berufen,
die dann aber alle ineinander greifen zu einer extrem professionellen und tollen Mannschaft.
Robert du hast dich heute sehr gut geschlagen.
Ich darf dir meinen persönlichen Bachelor überreichen.
Danke.
Dankeschön.
Gratuliere.